يستعدون للظفر بواحده من مئات اسماك الرنج
ما تشاهدونه يعد واحدا من اقدم واشهر
الكرنفالات في فرنسا واكثرها صخبا مهرجان
دنكيرك السنوي احتفال فريد يعود لمئات
السنين بدا كعيدا لتكريم الصيادين
المحليين واصبح الان واحدا من اضخم
المهرجانات في البلاد
اللافت ان المهرجان يستمر لنحو ثلاثه اشهر
ميناير وحتى مارس تبلغ ذروه الاحتفالات في
الايام الثلاثه الاخيره له وفيها تقصر رمي
سمك الرينجا حيث يتوافد عشرات الالاف الى
الساحه المواجهه لمبنى البلديه يطل عمده
المدينه من شرفه برج الجرس وهو بالمناسبه
احد مواقع التراث العالمي ليلقي هو وضيوفه
نحو نصف طن من اسماك الرنجه على المحتفلين
وسط تدافع كبير للفوز بواحده منها
[موسيقى]